Here we are in Module 3.
And this module is about change of character vs.
break of structure. So, little explanation about those
if you don't already know. I'm sure I would expect at least 90% of
you would already know what a change of character is and what a break
of structure is. But before I walk you over it on the indicator,
let's just walk over what it is now.
Change of character, also known as Chuck.
That is literally just a break of the change in trend.
Like, it says it in the name, change of character.
It's just a change in trend. It's a shift that happens and it can
only happen once. In one direction before it happens again the other way.
Whereas a break of structure is just a continuation in trend.
So, let's say, you know,
what we learned earlier about swing structure. We knew this was a swing low,
we knew this was a swing high. This was a higher low,
higher than this high, here. Then price continued from
here to the upside. Putting in a new high,
a higher high, higher than the previous high,
okay. This here is what we would call a breaker structure,
because it breaks the swing high.
Okay, When that breaks,
either to the downside or the upside, that's either a breaker structure or a
change in character. It changes to the upside,
so we had a breaker structure. Then we had a pullback.
Then we had a reversal.
Remember what I said in the previous one though, this low cannot be confirmed
until the high has gone.
So when price then trades through that high,
this is a new confirmed swing low, and it's higher than the previous low,
so it's a higher low. And then,
we have a continuation, after this break structure,
we trade up to here before we then reverse, okay.
Price then continues to the downside, this is the swing low at this point,
so we're expecting this low to hold.
But what happens? You can see price trades straight through that low.
That is what you would call a change of character.
That is a change in trend. We've just gone from bullish to bearish.
So there's our change of character, okay? That's a very simple explanation like that.
Change of character is actually very, very simple.
And it's going to be even more simpler when you actually look at it
on the indicator because it's done for you. So there's the change of character.
We've already gone over a break structure, but I'll also walk through what a
break structure is. It's just a continuation.
Hi. Low, low or high,
low in the previous high, low or low,
this low or low being put in place, breaking a structural low is
a breaker structure. Now,
let's just remove this, right?
Imagine price is then playing out,
okay, so this is price from a high coming down,
we have a low put in place, we know this is a valid low
because we've had a pullback, and what do we
then see? Okay, well price is now trading to the downside,
remember this cannot be confirmed as a high until this low is taken
because price could reverse from here and continue higher,
this would not be a structural shift,
break, change of capital. actor or anything like that, because internal of
this high and this low, remember these are our swing points,
swing high, swing low, we're in this range right now,
you just use Use the box method, drag a box from the high to
the low. Anything from inside of here is internal.
So only when price breaks out of this box can we have a valid
breaker structure. So then price continues to the downside.
Breaking to the downside is internal.
The breaker structure here. It's that simple.
Okay? This is what we call a breaker structure.
Now we can just simply walk through it on, Why does it disappear?
Now we can just simply walk through it on the chart.
It's very simple because it's done for you.
Okay? Now, all you have to do is watch price play
out. Genuinely. Like, the education behind it
is what I've just given you. Right? Now we're just going to watch price
play out. So, right now,
where is our swing low? Well, you can see very clearly,
this is our swing low. Because it's already marked out by the
indicator. Where's our swing high at this point?
Well, you may notice you can't see a swing high,
but you can see a dyed line. The reason there's no swing high yet
is because there hasn't been a valid pullback. So like I just mentioned there,
right, price can continue from here and trade higher.
Meaning that, one
second, let me move that from the screen.
Yeah, so price can continue and trade higher from here,
meaning that this dyed line that is currently printing.
Would continue higher. It would move until we had it pulled back.
So let's just play that out and see what happens. We know this is
our swing low. Okay, we broke the last swing high.
This was the high that put this swing low in place.
That's been traded through, which is why there's a breaker structure.
But we're yet to have a swing high.
So we have to wait for a pullback.
So price would continue. We know we're in a bullish trend.
Let's play. One more of those candles and we have a
pullback. Now that is a valid pullback.
And that's why the indicator has just placed the swing high.
So now we know, based on this trend, right,
this low and this high are our swing points.
What do we do with this information? I'm in the day time frame.
Well, I know we had a change of character down here.
Then we've had a continuation. This was the highest point of the change of
character. For a pullback,
we had a pullback. This was the low before the price continued to go
up. I'm in having a brick structure. I know that we're printing higher highs
and higher lows right now, so we're in a bullish trend,
okay? This is the bullish trend right now.
So with this information, I could expect this low.
To be strong, and this high to be weak.
Let's play out. Okay.
Now for this, for this module,
of course, we're trying to understand break structure and change of character.
What would be a break structure here, and what would be a change of
character? Okay. For those of you that said,
if the low was taken as a change of character,
then you would be correct. Okay. If this low goes,
it's a change of character. If this high goes, it's break structure,
it's a continuation. Okay.
Let's play it out. Okay. The low was gone. So we've just shifted to
the downside. That is our change in trend,
our chalk, our change of character, whatever you want to call it.
Okay. Now, you see again,
that there is only a dotted line. There's no swing low confirmed yet.
Okay. We're open. We have a swing high confirmed.
This is our swing high. This has now become a strong high.
Because we're going to change the character to the downside. Because now I'm expecting
price to continue to the downside. And. and This to be protected.
Okay. Let me move the pan.
Only when we have a pullback. Will we know that
there's a swing low in place? And that pullback is done based on the
rule that we have, right? Some of you may know it. Some of you
may know, but it's a three-candable. Not just any three candles,
okay? It has to be a certain order of candles as waves.
You noticed here, right? There's more than three candles here.
But that doesn't class as a,
as a pullback. The high wouldn't be there, right?
There's four candles there. There's five candles there.
Six candles there. Seven candles.
We still haven't had a pullback, okay? There's a certain rule that we have
that qualifies a pullback. You can see here,
right? We've had a change of cad- to the downside.
Had one candle pullback, two candles, three, four.
We're still yet to confirm a swing glove. See, the low didn't
confirm. Okay? Still not confirmed.
Still not confirmed. I'm sorry. We're still waiting for our low to be confirmed.
Boom. There we have it. Swing low.
Okay? So now I know my range is from this high to this low.
This is where people can get. I think it's confused with structure.
Because if you're, If you don't have a rule to validate
a pullback, inside of here,
you could be believing this is a swing high,
this is a high, this is a low, and you'd be trading along the
wrong side of the market here. Boom.
Low. Still haven't had the pullback.
Remember, we're just looking now at our swing points.
This was the low that put in place. This had a valid pullback,
which is why the low was put there. Then price reverse from here.
we can that low, having a breaker structure. Prices had a breaker
to the downside. We are yet to have a valid pullback.
Now we've confirmed a valid pullback, meaning now this high is our swing high.
This is our swing glow. Which side is protected?
This side. This is a strong high. This is a weak glow.
We expect this low to go. So we use that in our advantage.
We want to be looking for shorts at the right time. To take this
low. Again,
breaker structure. To the downside.
This becomes a new swing high because this was the highest point before price
break to the downside. So we have our strong higher already.
You always have your strong high or low once there's been a break.
Now, depending on the trend. Low if we're in a bullish trend.
Now what we're waiting for again is the
free kind of pullback rule. Hasn't happened yet.
Hasn't happened. Boom.
Happened. So now we have a new range.
High, low.
Low is still weak, because we're still bearish.
So we're still shorting. We should be shorting this whole leg.
Low is gone. This becomes a new high,
because this is the highest point. After the break,
the highest point after the break. Remember that.
So we have our swing high, but now we're waiting for a pullback.
We've had a valid pullback, so it's this high,
this low, this low. The weak, this low,
this high strung.
We have internal structure printed now. Boom.
Now, this becomes our swing high.
Why? Because it's the highest point after this break.
So after we broke here, where's the highest point of the pullback?
Here. Sift can the swing high. Can't break structure.
We gotta now wait for our pullback wall. We've had the pullback wall.
So this becomes our swing low. Now it's this high and this low.
Remember, this high is strong. This low is weak still.
Unless we have a change of character. Boom.
Now we've done it again. We're just continuing this trend.
This whole time in here, after this change of character,
we should have been shorting from these highs. Which is exactly what's playing out.
Then, after this break structure,
the swing high becomes the highest point. I went before the break.
Okay, so we broke here. After this break,
the pullback. This is the highest point in the pullback. Then we broke.
That becomes the swing high. Now we have our pullback to confirm the low.
Still no pullback. Value pullback now has happened.
So now it's d- It's high in this low. Break structure
again. I'll wait until we have a change of character.
And then we wrap that up.
Right now we're this high and this low.
We know that we're still bearish. We have an internal structure put in place.
Break again. Just continuing the bearish trend.
It's how
this, this indicator is just,
the trend's perfect every single time.
All right. Break
again. Internal,
internal, internal break.
There you go. Not how to change a character.
Why is this this change of character? Simply put,
because, We've just come from bearish.
You can see the bearish trend. I
put any lower lows and lower highs to a shift.
We've just took this swing high. Of course,
any change of character. We just, come from bearish to bullish,
okay? Yet to have a pullback.
To place a new swing high. Now I've had a swing high and I
will continue the bullish trend. Just like we did with the bearish
one. But yeah,
that is this module wrapped up.
It's quite simple. Get rid of that.
If you have any questions, just drop me,
drop me a tag, add me,
like in the community or something, add me, tag me. Ask the questions.
Very simple. It's, you know,
it's done for you in a day. You just need to be able to
follow it and understand the purpose of it. Okay?